dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly jonatha here in this
series we have studied fluid simulations
extensively but we haven't talked about
one important quantity that describes a
fluid and this quantity is none other
than viscosity viscosity means the
resistance of a fluid against
deformation the large viscosity of honey
makes it highly resistant to deformation
and this is responsible for its famous
and beautiful coiling effect water
however does not have a lot of
objections against affirmations making
it so easy to pour it into a glass with
this piece of work it is possible to
efficiently simulate the motion of
fluids and not only that but it also
supports the simulation of a large range
of viscosities viscosities can also
change in time for instance physicists
know that raising the temperature will
make the viscosity of fluids decrease
which leads to melting therefore
decreasing the viscosity in time will
lead to a simulation result that looks
exactly like melting the technique also
supports to wake up link where the
objects have effects on the fluid and
vice versa
one can also put multiple fluids with
different densities and viscosities into
the same domain and see how they Duke it
out this is exactly what people need in
the industry robust techniques that work
for small and large scale simulations
with multiple objects and material
settings that can possibly change in
time thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time